you've probably never thought I wish
fallout was more like Wind Waker
but with this cel-shading mod you might
well change your mind I'm Kate and this
is your GameSpot news update the fallout
4 community has already shown off what
the RPG would look like with higher
resolution graphics but a new fan made
visual tweet goes in a different
direction
redditor reddit is wrong adjusted the
game's visuals to depict the game with
Borderlands style cell shape graphics
this was made possible by altering the
sweet FX reshape ENB injector file and
using a combination of other mods the
full set of instructions for how to try
this out for yourself is available on BG
24/7 I started off with a sweet FX
preset to fallout 4 and then tweaked the
any file to turn on the cartoon cel
shader the user wrote you can customize
the any file to your liking and how
strong the border its reddit is wrong
went on to say that fallout 4 might have
been better suited with this out style
as opposed to the realistic aesthetic
that it aims for for its part developer
Bethesda admitted that it dialed back
the game's graphics in part to allow the
studio to deliver a deep level of
interactivity what do you make of this
graphic style for fallout 4 let us know
in the comments below or come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
remember to keep it GameSpot calm for
all your fallout 4 update and make sure
to check out our fallout 4 show and
thanks for watching